[Music]
starting off this hour
is caitlin in houston texas hey caitlin
what's up in your world
hey dave and john thanks for taking my
call sure
how can we help hey um so my fiance and
i were due to get married in about two
weeks
and um i'm due with our first in
september um
my question is about prenup um i've
heard you talk about them previously but
not as it relates to a business
and he's brought it up once before i
explained to him
why i don't like them and i actually
sent him a podcast you did on it
and apparently he understood from there
and the subject was
dropped but he's brought it up again and
he wants his business land
money he's acquired to this point all in
the prenup
so i i i don't know what to tell him or
how to help him
understand my perspective or maybe i'm
wrong about businesses and a prenup
um he had a previous business partner go
through a divorce and the wife tried to
take part in the business so
i think that's part of his concern
that i don't know what to tell him or
how to go what's he making what's he
make on this business
um he makes he has a 50 50 partner and
he makes about
67 000 a year okay
whoopty yeah yeah i was going to say
high five man
yeah that's awesome but i mean he
doesn't make 680 000 a year
so um
i i have a lot of thoughts um
and most of them are too mean to say out
loud without filtering them so um
and it's hard for me to be quiet because
i've got a lot of mean thoughts in my
head
well you you go first hey caitlin i
don't like here's me and john here we go
i'm gonna go nice i don't like prenups i
don't like them
it feels like you're walking into
something that there should not be an
exit strategy for
with at least a crack in the door or a
toe out the door
unless you've got some really complex
situations
i just don't like him and i get that
he's seen somebody get burned that makes
sense to me what i don't like is
you guys sat down and had this
conversation you talked about it
you made peace with it and then two
weeks out
he circled back and that feels like a
move to me that feels like a
a move that lacks integrity yeah like
this discussion should i had before we
made a baby
and it sounds like you did have it right
and this discussion should have been had
before we were two weeks from marriage
yeah this is this is right previously he
just
i i basically i said no and he and i
and he agreed with the you agreed with
our stance on the podcast so our stance
on the podcast is what john is saying
okay and i'll repeat what i probably
said then because it's what i say every
time i get this question okay
if everything is fairly equal and this
is fairly equal
i would not marry someone that required
a prenup
because you are planning your failure
you're planning your failure and there's
he loves his business his
half of his business more than you he's
more worried about his business partner
than you and that's just
he didn't mean to say that but this
action says that
and so no no now the only and i used to
when i first started this and you heard
this on that podcast probably
because i almost always say this i used
to say no prenups ever the only time i
say
a prenup is a good idea is in extreme
situation that's why i
asked about the size of the business if
he's making a million dollars a year on
this business and they own 20 million
worth of property and you got nothing
yeah that's an extreme situation
and that would warrant the
differentiation is a
the difference is a extreme situation
and even then
i'm probably not 50 of the prenup is for
the actual marriage
but 50 of it is for both of your crazy
relatives
because uncle crazy as a june bug shows
up and decides he wants
your uncle crazy june bug decides he
wants a piece of your husband's business
that was there before you were
or uncle junebug showed up and uh and
you can just throw up your hands and go
i can't help you i got a prenup and so
it keeps the weirdness of your extended
family in line
and all extended family has weirdness
it's just every family
so that's it's good in extreme
situations this is not extreme enough
this has to do with
he was wounded by the other deal and
he's extrapolating that into your new
marriage and that
is not good medicine right
here's my concern for you this leaves
you really exposed either way right
because now you're having to either go
into a marriage and sign a piece of
paper that you don't feel comfortable
marrying
which is going to put a wedge between
you and this guy that you are tethering
yourself to for the rest of your life
or you're going to be a single mom here
in september
right yeah so he's put you in an
impossible situation
and that's why even beyond the prenup
i'll even go as far to say i get that
he's been burned and he's been hurt
before
and that's a scar fresh on his soul i
get that cool
i don't like that he waits till two that
feels like a move to me and that feels
like somebody that's gonna pull move
after move after move on you here in the
future and even if he wasn't
meaningful meaning to do that and was
manipulative right
he has unbelievably bad timing right
yeah yeah at a minimum yeah that's
giving him the benefit of the doubt
i mean you know you you you settle this
before we make babies before we get
engaged right
and hey here's here's the bigger thing
dave i know
there's millions of people that are
going to hear this and say that's stupid
that is stupid you got to protect
yourself if they say that they're stupid
i wasn't going to say that but here's
what i was going to say if that's your
first response then don't get married
yeah yeah don't get married let me give
you a weird the weirdest one i ever had
was a lady called and said
uh my fiance has a classic 1968 mustang
that's worth 140 000 that he built frame
up and he wants a prenup to protect that
and uh papa dave said don't marry him
yep
what don't marry him he loves this
stupid car
more than you that's right don't marry
him if it's my daughter i'd run that guy
off with a gun
right no do not marry him this is not
marriage material
he has his priorities all screwed up
if you love a car more than you love
your fiance
you are not marriage material and it
will move over time that car will become
a boat which will become a house which
will become a
my kid's going to this college and
nobody else it will become a thing
it has to be i'll take a bullet for you
it's the only shot you've got
i'm making it through a marriage yeah
because there is you've got to
you got to burn all the boats man
because marriage is hard yeah it's
everybody's going to have a moment where
you go i'm done with you i'm out
i'm out and if you say you haven't had
that then you haven't been married and
you're lying and then you got to run
before you're lying you got to run to
the shore and realize oh i don't have
any bugs oh god
yeah there's nowhere to go i got no i
can't drive off of my classic car
because again you know
and so yeah you got to make it work i
want somebody that will look at my
daughter
and my son and say i'll set that car on
fire for you
yeah that's the guy that's going to sit
at my kitchen table yeah right and this
business
is how i make a living and i love my
business and i love being in business
but it doesn't even show up on the same
spectrum oh welcome i love it all
tomorrow
my love for you now play that one back
for bubba